it's time for drew's news where we love
to cut loose and shake that good news
caboose and with me at the desk is a man
with the fanciest feet in the news rossy
ross matthew hello everybody
i love where you shake your caboose
i mean i hear the word caboose i'm going
to shake it well today we have a very
special guest um i'm so excited she's
here she just kicked off her fourth
season
on saturday night live
here's a clip from this past saturday
take a look
later we'll talk about biden's
infrastructure bills but first crock pot
lasagna now this sounds gross to me
anyone else you know i have a question
what's an air fryer what is it
ladies if something's fried i'll eat it
dede don't talk like that
please
[Applause]
wow
i am so excited that you are here i'm so
excited to be here and such a warm
audience you guys are gay
well rosie should we get into some
headlines we should first i have to ask
you know cause snl and everybody's
talking kim kardashian west is hosting
um
how are we feeling
um excited heidi and i recently did
interviews where we were talking about
how excited we are i know some people
have been throwing some shade and i was
like i'm going to throw some sunlight
into the situation yes and make it a
beach and it's all good like it's
exciting it's exciting i throw a little
a little sunlight
have you met her before i've never met
her when kanye was the musical guest in
my very first episode um i called
by the way full circle too exactly
exactly
kim was there i think with north but i
have not met her i saw her watching his
performance and it was my first day of
like formal work my first formal
saturday so i'll get to meet her i get
to be like buddies with her this weekend
who the heck is throwing shade about kim
kardashian being on snl esteban's lucky
to have her she's lucky to be doing it
this is a match made in heaven
i think their viewership is going to
show everybody that they were wrong i
love kim what's that what she's a
cultural icon hello
hello
[Applause]
yeah i think so too what's so exciting
about the show is getting to take
someone who is not in the comedy scene
or who isn't an actor known as an actor
and putting them into like sketch comedy
on live television and they're like a
fish out of water and like our job is to
make them look good and funny and like
maybe show them in the world that they
can do this thing that they perhaps
never consider doing ego are you ready
to hit those headlines yes let's get
into it all right well we gotta start
with huge adele news because she just
announced a brand new single
it's coming out october 15th it's called
easy on me we have a tease check it out
[Music]
i'm like where's the voice i know are
you kidding me
that isn't real cheese that's a real
cheese after what we have been through
as a world we need you adele right now
because i don't know
i don't know how to process my feelings
until adele tells me how to feel
i
you're with me right as soon as we set
it down the whole audience goes why i
need this mass
ugly cry with all of you
thank you adele
what if that song when i hear the title
easy on me i was i'm sort of like yeah
she's going to help us process the whole
pandemic everything that's going on and
what if it's like her take is the
pandemic's been easy on me right
everyone's going to low-key hate that
well i mean she certainly you know has
evolved and thrived throughout the
pandemic i mean she i mean really
changed her whole life yeah um you know
but i think when she talks about
love
it's
kind of like no one else when they talk
about love yeah so i'll be curious to
see what this album has in store for it
yeah and it's been about six years adele
it's time thank you yes thank you and
this one's called 30 but she's actually
33 because they're always a number of
her age so i'm like is this a whole
three-year odyssey i mean we've all been
through a three-year odyssey so maybe
she's gone really hollywood and she's
like no i'm still 30. right
well she does look great
all right ttmo time to move on okay
hey so you're uh you're joining us here
today
okay
dude i like it i like it i like it all
right we love that you're here at the
desk and one thing we love to do here is
make sure our guests are well fed so
it's time for some food news
okay we got food right here the detroit
news reports hometown hero m m has just
opened a brand new restaurant called
mom's spaghetti it's inspired by a
famous lyrics from lose yourself and the
song from eight mile and today we do
have mom spaghetti right here uh it's an
interesting take on the classic
they serve it reheat style they cook the
pasta before and then they heat it up in
a wok for that leftover feel this is a
tv exclusive we have this is really it
from detroit okay mom
now listen
i've always thought that the only thing
better than italian food it's leftover
reheated italian food so i'm thank you
i'm all about all right
[Applause]
okay
that was really good okay really really
good
really good this is so incredible
you want a meatball to taste like that
classic
why they got to put the camera on me
when i'm taking the big bite
oh i stepped an entire ball in my mind
i see you
i love him him so much like i think he's
like
the greatest yeah this one doesn't like
he's my goat i gotta tell i just think
he's so
ugh
i do and this is just
another nail in my coffin of love for
him now do you love eminem as a what is
going on
as a rapper
okay say less say even say
say even less than you're already know i
have a total crush on him absolutely
who doesn't by the way out there on
television you have a crush on that
crush oh my god am i yeah
that's a crush you've added yourself
uh-huh that is yourself
[Applause]
now i just want to say this is very good
i mean i'm i'm not going to stop eating
so i know me too i'm like ross if you
want to uh take us out actually so i can
eat keep eating mom's spaghetti
um egg wooden thank you so much for
being here
is all new this saturday live coast to
coast with kim kardashian west as host
and the musical guest halsey
she's going to be great people are
terrified to host live
spaghetti
that's gonna be my last sentence
[Music]
you